this is a friendly message or a word of
warning depending on how you want to
take it for the new leaders of Syria
whoever they turn out to be they're
still figuring things out over there to
the new leaders of Syria I
say we agree with you on something
Bashar al-assad is an evil Tyrant here
in the US we don't like evil tyrants our
nation was founded on the idea that
people have the right to rebel against
oppressors our constitution and Bill of
Rights were designed to keep a tyrant
from controlling us so why you may
Wonder didn't more of us support your
Rebellion against
Assad well it's because we think that as
sick and sadistic as Assad is some of
the groups fighting to replace him are
significantly worse in other words even
though we are absolutely repulsed by
Assad and the horrifying things he's
done done we have no reason to think
that you'll be any better and we have
serious concerns that you'll be
worse but you now have an opportunity to
prove us wrong you can show the world
that you're better than that evil Tyrant
and that we should have been cheering
you on all
along how can you show us that you're
better than Assad you can show us you're
better than Assad by not using your new
power to oppress the people people of
Syria I'm specifically thinking about
groups that some in your ranks might
want to Target Christians Drew Kurds
yazidis Shia and so on I understand that
there are dangerous individuals and
groups that you have to deal with that's
the reality of the situation but there
are also millions of people who just
want to live their lives earn a living
take care of their kids and build a
future these are the people who
shouldn't be mistreated and yet we know
that there are jihadis among you who
want to mistreat these
people we also know that it's easy to
focus on the battle at hand and to lose
sight of the bigger picture it's easy to
say we're finally in charge now we can
subjugate everyone we disagree
with but the world is watching that's
the bigger picture we're watching what
you do we're watching to see how you
treat the Christians we're watching to
see how you treat the Drews we're
watching to see how you treat the aides
we're watching to see how you treat
women and
children what do you want us to see do
you want people around the world looking
at what you do and saying oh my goodness
things were so much better when Bashar
al-assad was in
power or do you want people saying wow
it's great that that Assad was
overthrown because Syria is is so much
better without
him what you do in the coming months and
years will decide what we think about
you and how we remember Assad it's all
in your hands we hope you'll make good
decisions that benefit all the people
who want to get along in order to build
a better
Syria but you might be tempted to go the
Sharia route turning Christians into
demies making them pay jizya forcing
women and girls to become your sexual
servants things like that
but that would be incredibly
shortsighted you may have been so
focused on local battles over the past
decade that you missed what's been
happening in the rest of the
world you may not know that there are a
lot of people who really really don't
like your Prophet millions of people are
leaving Islam tons of people are online
exposing Muhammad and the Quran so many
people are leaving Islam that it's
called the Avalanche of apostasy
the main reason so many people are
turning against Muhammad is that they
see what happens when groups like yours
get power over others they see your
Prophet as the prophet of violence
oppression and cruelty and they reject
him so what are you going to
do are you going to turn even more
people against Islam are you going to
convince more Muslims to become
apostates are you going to cause even
more people to to criticize and condemn
your religion are you going to
accelerate the Avalanche of
apostasy the choice is yours and you
know what we'll be
watching and if we see you op
pressing the people of Syria we're going
to make sure the world blames your
prophet in fact I'll make you this
promise if you use your new power to
subjugate and abuse our Christian
Brothers and
sisters we will expose your prophet and
your book so brutally so
mercilessly that you will beg to return
to the days of Bashar al-assad